good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and ASCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 1280 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 1280 cultures should be maintained
at 20 degrees and inspected weekly to
verify viability of specimens all
researchers working with these cultures
must follow procedures appropriate for
biosafety level 2 material and submit
weekly stool samples to allow detection
of accidental infection if eggs or
larvae are detected a course of
albendazole shall be applied until the
infection has cleared depending upon the
culture which produced the infection and
nazy acts may be given at the discretion
of the lead researcher human settlement
suspected of scp-1234 s beta 7 mass
Hatters under the guise of a
humanitarian aid organization the entire
population should be treated for
hookworm infection and a standard
hygiene intervention should be performed
including but not limited to
establishment of sealed latrines and
elimination of open-air middens
depending on the extent and duration of
the infestation amnesiacs and
supplementary psychological counseling
may be required to establish social
boundaries description SCP 1280 is a
parasitic nematode worm superficially
identical to NECA tor americanus new
world hookworm it's life cycle is the
same as an americanus with falero form
juveniles burrowing through the skin
finding their way through the
bloodstream to the lungs and eventually
reaching the small intestine where they
mature and reproduce infestations can
cause all of the typical symptoms of
hookworm infection in humans including
weight loss lassitude and anemia
as CP 1280 differs from an American s in
several respects genomic comparison of
specimens with reference organisms
reveals obvious modifications a marker
sequence appears repeatedly in sections
which are junk DNA in the reference
organism more significantly a number of
novel sequences appear in the place of
redundant genes in n americanus these
appear in no other genome and foundation
databases and is believed that the
enzymes and hormones for which they code
are responsible for the organisms
anomalous effects for these reasons SCP
1280 has been assigned the provisional
designation and americanus x Mnemosyne
adult worms in the intestine
periodically release a complex mixture
of hormone analogues and modified
neurotransmitters into the hosts
bloodstream some of these molecules are
capable of crossing the blood-brain
barrier and cause subtle changes in the
hippocampus and other brain regions via
an unknown mechanism these modifications
have two major effects hosts experience
significant improvements to both spatial
and visual memory increasing over time
until nearly photographic recall is
achieved memories formed prior to
infestation are not subject to eidetic
recall sense memories other than visual
are not affected to the same degree
additionally most brains begin to
excrete chemical messengers back into
the bloodstream which are filtered out
of the blood by the worms and stored in
a diverticulum off of their main gut
structure through a purling understood
mechanism some of these molecules are
passed along to offspring and eggs
periodically adult worms regurgitate
tiny amounts back into the hosts
bloodstream causing unbidden recall of
seemingly random visual memories upon
reaching the brain
it appears that each packet of these
compounds corresponds to a single visual
memory
because worms inherit some of these
packages from their progenitors adult
worms hold a mixture of encoded memories
from every host in their lineage with an
abundance correlated to the generational
distance between the current host and
the originator hosts respond to foreign
messages in the same way as endogenous
ones a sudden vivid recollection of
events which they may not have
experienced firsthand once experienced
in this manner foreign memories are
stored normally in the brain and may be
recalled in the presence of appropriate
stimulus the organism responds normally
to anti hookworm interventions
once all worms are cleared from the body
extraordinary powers of recall a road
until back to baseline any memories
formed during the period of an
infestation will remain in human
settlements with low standards of
Hygiene these effects can have serious
impacts on the social structure of the
community in villages with common open
latrines members constantly exchange
populations of worms the exchange of
memories in this manner can lead to the
erosion of personal identity as members
lose track of which events they
experience directly in which were
remembered second hand in one extremely
advanced infestation members of an
entire village referred to themselves by
a single given name and displayed
behaviors seen previously only in
colonies of you social insects the
organism was first identified during an
outbreak in in West Africa 2000 the
nematodes were limited to a sharply
defined area in a 2 kilometer radius
around the settlement and some evidence
was found of aerosolized deployment
presumably from a crop duster type
aircraft subsequently additional
infestations have been discovered in
rural areas of sub-saharan Africa and
South Asia with a smaller number of
cases in Central America and the
southern United States
I think that's where we should leave it
today thank you all very much for
listening if indeed you still are and
you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you
[Music]